um
i i don't know if
i don't know i made myself clear what i
was trying to get at uh are you
maybe i i should ask a question first
are you proposing that you can do
physics at priori
uh because that doesn't seem to be the
case
um
we tried to do physics out prior that
stateheart's project and it collapses
you can't do physics out prior you see
as you said and then you said we can
observe regularities which i think is
what physics does but that means you're
saying that regularities are really
there um and then i guess the problem
becomes
uh
what privileges those experiences of i
mean i can have to use your analogy i
can have regularities in my dream and i
don't take them to have given me
an account of how the world really is
but if i do say that regularities work
what is it about them that gets me
outside of
the simulation i'm worried about i'm
worried about a problem of skepticism
here i'm worried about a problem of
right am i this is what you know this is
what hume does he says well
you know uh
you've got all these regularities but
those regularities are themselves only
projected by the mind their causation is
just association between
ideas and experiences and therefore i
really can't know the world
and kant et cetera and so i i guess
i'm wondering if there seems to be a i
mean
to say things are a projection is to say
that other things are real because it's
a contrast term to say that everything
is an illusion for example doesn't make
any sense it's like saying everything's
tall
right um so i'm trying to get out what
is like what surely we must have
experiences that count as access to the
real or else we are just locked inside
an attorney an internal self-referential
system that's what i'm that's what i'm
asking
that make sense um yes but let's start
out with um one of these aspects there
are several um points that we i think
would need to address and some of them
are veritable rabbit holes so let's
start out with the problem of skepticism
personally i don't see skepticism as a
problem because i think that uh when i
am
observing um the trajectories that my
mind can take
there is not usually many points where i
open a door and go through and i cannot
go back
right it's not that i uh in the course
of intellectual exploration uh go
through one-way doors
that i can see before and i say um
i cannot come back this might exist in
some religions so uh here is a wonderful
delicious brain worm uh you take it on
and you can give it back in three weeks
from now and ideologies uh usually work
in such a way that they warp your mind
in such a way that you get cut off from
the rest of human thought space and you
cannot come back
and i i think that in the rational world
this cannot happen so when you think
rationally
everything that you think is conditional
on something else
and so
everything that is not impossible is
possible
and the confidence among the possible
things has to be disputed uh distributed
according to the evidence that is
available
so the possibility that
nothing exists in the way in which i
perceive it and i don't exist and other
people don't exist or only i exist and
all the other people exist is always a
possibility and there is nothing scary
about it and they don't need to be
worried about it there are no
assumptions that they need to make to
avoid this so i never fall into this
trap and never come back oh my god no
it's not not a problem the possibility
that there are no other people
should be considered
and i should see uh what observations
suggest that this is the case and which
observations speak against it and uh if
i ever find out that there never been
other people why should i be surprised
right it's i should consider this i
should see how deep the rabbit hole goes
there's nothing scary about it's not
infinitely deep they're not infinitely
many conclusions that i will draw from
this this will not lock me in an
inhospitable place of the intellectual
universe if i consider this path so i
would suggest basically consider the
entire space of possibilities and the
idea that there are other minds in the
world that are constituted in a quite
similar way to mine but have a larger
diversity than some people might be
willing to acknowledge at first glance
and so on right this seems to be a good
theory there seem to be other objects
that look a lot like me in this mind and
they seem to be like me the side effect
of the regulation needs of the hairless
monkey
in the present universe and uh
this so it's a good theory it gives good
predictions it's a useful encoding of
the patterns that are thrown at my
systemic boundary
and
this there's another aspect to solipsism
which is more an experiential one this
is if you cannot perceive other minds as
minds based on the priors that you have
most people don't learn a lot of wisdom
in their life and that their wisdom they
have is largely a structure that is
innate to them they are lucky to be born
bias
and they just converge in the
observation of the world to more details
in this structure and so only people
that are born unwise have difficulty to
ever get to wisdom so we do learn new
structure but largely the architecture
that we use to interpret the world seems
to be
something that is
to a large degree innate that is mapped
to the circumstances that our ancestors
found themselves in in the world and
what we noticed for instance many
europeans that live in the us
have all these weird quirks in which
they relate to the world that are the
remnant of non-existent european
societies that they're brought
within their own minds and the structure
that is built into their soul over many
generations and now
they try this in this very brutish and
weird pioneer society that is the u.s
and many of these patterns don't make
sense and this is not just the case for
europeans it's just for europeans i can
notice and interpret these patterns
better than for other cultures that are
part of this hodgepodge of the
u.s and so it's very interesting to see
that uh solipsism might be a property of
some people i i sometimes think that our
previous president has been a solipsist
not in the sense that he is an evil
person i think it's psychologically
interesting that when he talks to other
people his important criterion was
always
he can't say whatever he wants as long
as he gets away with it and
communication is a tool to get what he
wants
and it seems to be somewhat invariant in
politics but he beelines for it right he
is able to think outside of a box
because he never acknowledged the
existence of this box
there is a certain prior that there are
other minds that he need to share truth
with
that is absent he can just say whatever
he wants he's free to do this because
there are no other people
there's only something like an almost
faceless audience that relates to him in
a particular way and that he relates to
in a particular way that makes him fit
for this particular role was probably
unwise to to make this tangent because
they don't want to make a normative
statement one way or the other about
trump they just think that he happens to
be somebody that we all know and who's
psychologically interesting because i
think he might be a sole obsessed in an
experiential functional not necessarily
a philosophical sense
so don't worry josh i'm not going to
draw you into any kind of political
debate around uh uh trump
um so that uh that would be uh unfair to
you and unfair to the spirit in which
you offered the example um
now uh i'm trying to think of what how
to reply because you said about seven
thousand really interesting things in
that last thing uh but one thing i i i
seemed to pick up on
uh was that you know
reality seems to be determined by
rational processes of making sense
um which
i mean and that's a classical kind of
idealism that's sort of like hegelian
idealism that ultimately the real is
dependent on
on the on the capacity for rationality
and so rationally has to be as real as
anything else because of that dependency
relationship
now the thing about that is rationality
seems to be
a quintessential mental property too
um
and
does that mean
that we don't have
i mean
you know you know you know this too i
know you know what again i've seen your
talks you know the problems of deep time
that idealism faces right the problem
with deep time
you know
there seems to be a significant
difference between darwin discovering
the theory of evolution in 1859 process
of rational reflection gathering the
evidence and the process of evolution
that actually led to darwin's existence
right they have different they have
different temporal uh spatial extensions
etc and so
the the problem
i guess i'm trying to get at is
when i'm talking about it that way
doesn't that mean that i have to
take it that that rationality really
exists since my ability to
determine what is real is dependent on
my rational processes like you said
better theories worth series making
better sense
etc etc and then that seems to indicate
a very high level of organization at
which things can be real
rather than just
what is typically taken to be
the physical i take it that at least
traditionally at least currently
rationality is not part of the ontology
of physics it's presupposed in the
practice of physics but it's not part of
the ontology um
and so that that means it sounds to me
either like you have a kind of strong
idealism or because you brought this up
as another possibility
you see rationality as emerging uh
perhaps out of intelligence and
intelligence emerging out of the
behavior of the brain
but it wouldn't be an epiphany it could
not be given this argument at the
phenomenal emergence rationality would
have to be a real thing
that really exists and really uh
directs people's behavior in some
fashion
how does that land with you or have i
misinterpreted you